now as if the Roy Moore situation wasn't
bad enough Sean Hannity Fox News host
weirdly seemed to argue that everything
Roy Moore did was consensual which
ignores this little thing the serious
thing that I call statutory rape and now
advertisers are just running away they
are fleeing from Hannity's program
including one advertiser that i think is
going to help Pat out quite a bit in
terms of a recent scandal that he's been
wrapped up in I'll get more more about
that in a moment
after the Roy Moore allegations surfaced
the right-wing media machine kicked into
high gear and it's often the case that
they do this to defend the indefensible
and in comes Sean Hannity he's
interviewing Linda mcLaughlin I don't
know who that is but that's who he's
interviewing and it is bad bad bad when
Sean Hannity says hey listen this was
all consensual after all which ignores
as I said this thing called statutory
rape take a listen to this how do you
possibly tell no the truth except okay
so the two other girls were older in
this case he was apparently like 32 okay
and he dated one girl was 18 one girl
was 17 they never said he did it there's
no sexual there's kissing involved and
then they're saying this one encounter
with a potential and consensual that's
true and there's you know I just I don't
know how you find out the truth so it's
a little ambiguous right it kind of
seems like Sean Hannity is commenting on
the fourteen-year-old girl having been
involved in something that was
consensual although some others are
saying no he was only saying that the 16
to 18 year old girls were consensual and
they're above the age of consent and
Hannity says right oh yeah it was
consensual so my initial thought was
well is this another one of these
legitimate rape moments right is it was
it really statutory rape because
whatever Hannity thinks of as consensual
is what it was was it a semantic thing I
don't know but as a reminder the basis
of sexual consent laws are that a person
who is a minor by definition by statute
cannot legally consent period as a
society we've determined that no matter
what the
fourteen-year-old thinks they want to do
they're not mature enough to really be
able to make that call now this exploded
rightly so and then Sean Hannity ended
up having to do not one but two
apologies one was on Twitter and one was
on his show and after the show one he
went on Twitter and said as I said on TV
tonight
I apologize when I misspoke and was not
totally clear earlier today and then
went on to criticize the media similar
statement on his program about this but
it was too late right the advertisers
are running away from Hannity after they
ran away from Bill O'Reilly's programs
some time ago during his downfall on Fox
News
genetic testing company 23andme which I
used for our DNA test segment some time
ago they're bailing from the Hannity
show they've tweeted we've received
enquiries regarding advertising on
Hannity we are not running TV
advertising on Hannity we continue to
closely evaluate where we advertise
realtor.com says that they're out they
sent out a bunch of tweets to people
saying that they've pulled the ad
placements on the Hannity program they
since deleted those tweets I don't know
what was the PR strategy behind that but
one example of the tweets from
realtor.com Twitter account thanks for
bringing this to our attention we are
adjusting our media by to no longer
include this show placement and then
curing the coffee maker company that
uses pods famous on this program because
producer Pat uses it and has suffered at
the hands of many audience members as a
result of his use they are out out out
tweeting Angelo - Angelo carosone who I
know by the way interestingly enough
Angelo thank you for your concern and
for bringing this to our attention we
worked with our media partner and Fox
News to stop our ad from airing during
the sean hannity show the Keurig thing
has set people off I've got the Eggman
tweeting to me about it I've got people
saying Pat has been vindicated as a
result of this do you feel vindicated by
Keurig pulling ads from Hannity totally
vindicated I feel like I've weathered
the storm and I came out on top it's a
great feeling the crazy thing is Pat was
being criticized because Keurig makes
bad coffee not because anyone said it's
a bad company and somehow now the fact
that they've pulled the Hannity ads is
helping Pat we
you'll take I'm sure I'm gonna buy a new
one put it in the studio maybe ya Pat's
bring it Pat actually has an order for a
dozen Carrick's they're gonna be lined
up behind me here on the set but the
kirik thing has set people off somehow
the defense of child sexual predators
led to a cancellation of ads by Keurig
which has led to conservatives posting
videos of themselves smashing their
Keurigs in protest of Keurigs decision
and this is where we are in politics
right now I'm not gonna play any of the
videos of right-wingers destroying their
Keurig makers because I don't want to
give them any attention you can google
it and find lots of examples of it all
well and good ideally these companies
wouldn't have been advertising on Sean
Hannity's program in the first place but
progress is progress and the real
question here is and you know I would
get to it
how is the ROI more sec child sexual
assault scandal affecting the race since
this is an opportunity to take out a
reliable red seat and put a Democrat in
possibly Democrat Doug Jones let's go to
the latest polling